in the meantime the question is about a
twenty20 playing season what will it
look like in the NFL in the world of
kovat 19 I have in my hands 9 pages that
was kind of the the meet of the league
memo that went out to all 32 teams about
protocols for the 2020 season facility
protocols when players are expected to
be back hopefully later on this summer
and the chief medical officer of the
National Football League dr. Alan sills
we paged him did he call in Kris paging
dr. sills oh yeah he's on dr. sills how
are you sir great how are you I am doing
just fine let's get right into it here
dr. sills what would you want fans to
know about these nine pages that I'm
referring to the club protocol portion
of the memo that went out yesterday I
would want everyone to know that a
tremendous amount of research and review
and discussion and collaboration went
into that we had a number of joint task
forces that were set up between the NFL
and the NFL Players Association bringing
together
medical experts infectious disease
experts team doctors athletic trainers
players all those voices putting
together to really think about what's
the data telling us what is what is the
science showing us and with one simple
goal in mind which is how can we
mitigate risk and try to keep players
coaches and staff and everyone as safe
as possible during this pandemic while
we approach our season well it seems the
spine of this is to place personnel into
a tier there's three tiers I'll give you
the floor on what those tears are for
you to explain to people well I think
what we recognize is that you're going
to have really not just consideration
about fighters but an entire team
environment of people that are going to
be together every day so its players its
coaches and support staff medical staff
and those individuals are going to be in
and around the facility and also on the
practice field now when you're in your
facility certainly you can wear a mask
you can space things out it was there
physical distancing standing some of the
standard public health measures but when
you get on the football field we all
know that football and physical distance
you really don't go together so in that
sense those people who are in that close
tear together those those first two
tiers share risk with each other in
terms of transmission
also share responsibility responsibility
in the sense of what they're doing off
the field and away from the facility to
make sure they keep themselves as safe
as possible so all of those individuals
that we like to think of as one
ecosystem where again they're going to
have many of the similar risk factors
and the same factors around transmission
so we'll be testing them and screening
them and caring for them and trying to
protect them in the similar way it's
also important to note that we want to
limit the numbers in that because
obviously the more people that you bring
in the more you increase that risk so
we've asked clubs to really work with us
on that and determine how many people
really need to be in sort of those inner
circles of people that will share those
day-to-day risk with each other well and
in terms of that dr. Ellen sills I mean
you take a look at at a training camp
and the number of people just players
alone can number well above what any
locker room could handle when you've got
to make sure that lockers are a certain
distance apart
what what are you and in the league
instructing these teams to create extra
space I mean how are you gonna handle
that sort of thing there's no question
that this is going to require a lot of
challenging and thoughtful and creative
solutions but we have done just that and
we've talked and worked with teams and
part of centering these protocols out is
to give them the chance to prepare and
to think about those things I think one
of our team athletic trainers summed it
up best he said this is not going to
feel or look normal because it's not
going to be normal meaning that things
that we've become accustomed to our
day-to-day routines whether it be the
layout of the facility or how we conduct
meetings or how we conduct practices all
of those things are going to be likely
to change this season and they're going
to change to try to mitigate risk and to
keep everyone safe so there will be a
lot of accommodations that have to be
made and again that's things for example
taking meals together you know players
would typically come in and staff would
all eat together in one area you know we
have to change how that's done not only
how the food's prepared and distributed
but how people actually consume it so
basically everything in the operation of
the team is going to have to go through
that report for review through the lens
of how can we mitigate risk and make
this as safe as possible for everyone
right and there's you know obviously
we're hearing other leagues that are
trying to do this talking about creating
a community where everybody's in one
spot the NBA in particular talking about
Disneyworld right now we'll see what the
NHL comes up with but the NFL is not
gonna do that right I mean there's gonna
be just one facility that everyone's
gonna be at for training camp and then
the playing season is just going to be
what what do you what are you telling
the players going into playing season
well again we have a lot of
communication regularly with our
colleagues at the NFL Players
Association but we all did not feel that
we could take a six-month season which
is what our season ends up being I see
more than six months when you add in
training camp and ask everyone to stay
isolated at one location away from
family away from social network support
structure I mean that just felt like an
impractical request and additionally you
can't keep people locked down endlessly
and create some type of sterile
environment so we think that it's a
better approach is to do all that we can
to mitigate risk within the facility and
within the areas of football and then to
do a lot of education for all the
stakeholders that what we do away from
the football surface ility also really
matters here we have to really continue
to follow the best practices in terms of
wearing a mask frequent hand-washing
social distance physical distancing
these types of things because that's
what's going to help us all keep each
other safe and then we'll layer in with
that an aggressive screening and
surveillance testing program should
someone be exposed or contract illness
either outside or inside the facilities
where are you on that subject right now
yeah we're in very active discussions
again among all our advisors and in the
league and and the Players Association
together and and I'm optimistic that we
will see some updates on that in the
very near future again we have to
recognize that this is a very much a
moving target and all of these protocols
that you talked about they're going to
have to be very flexible and adaptable
because our knowledge is going to
continue to change we've got a long time
from now at the start of our season and
we're going to learn a lot more about
this virus we'll learn a lot more about
the pandemic we should take that
knowledge and make sure that we're
updating and modifying those protocols
to reflect the latest and best science
now I know dr. sills that you're again
you're you're a doctor you rely on
science you rely on science-based
conversation and
but what where do you want where do you
and the league want to be I mean do you
want to be in a spot where it's just if
somebody does test positive for Kovan
they're there just removed for a couple
of days depending on whatever the CDC
requirement will be for quarantine at
the time where do you want to be in
terms of keeping a league going when a
player tests positive well where we want
to be is squarely in line with the
public health guidance I think you've
seen throughout this pandemic that
that's been our strategy and you know
you could look back for example to the
draft and see that the challenge that we
took upon ourselves was how can we
conduct this draft but still do so in in
got in accordance with the current
Public Health guidelines and what's
being recommended to keep everyone safe
and also model that best behavior so
we're going to take the same approach
here we will have a very detailed
protocol for if someone tests positive
how they should be isolated how they
should be should should be treated and
how they may eventually return to play
but I think and we've said this
repeatedly we expect that there will be
new positive cases as long as this
disease remains endemic that doesn't
mean that our protocols failed or that
someone didn't do their job on their
personal responsibility as long as this
disease is endemic there'll be new
positive cases and so our goal is to
identify those as quickly and early as
we can in the infection window remove
those individuals away from everyone
else to keep everyone else safe and then
make sure they receive the appropriate
care and then return them to competition
or to their role as soon as it's safe to
do so
so it'd be is it gonna be sort of like
for the lack of a better phrasing oh
you're a neurosurgeon you know about the
concussion protocol is there gonna be
like a kovat 19 protocol where somebody
has to pass to become out of a kovat 19
protocol absolutely I think that's a
useful analogy and hey I always
appreciate you putting in terms I can
understand as a nursery nothing else for
you on that I can't can't go any further
I think there will be a road map to
follow and make sure that everyone has
received that appropriate treatment and
and again that will be constructed not
only in conduction with our medical
staff but what are the current cdc and
other public health guidelines as well
as what our experience has been from
other leaks I think one other important
to point out here's we're in regular
communication with other pro sports
leagues certainly throughout North
America and around the world and we're
learning from each other about their
initial experiences about how to return
sports and how to conduct these
protocols so all of that will help
inform those decisions then obviously
testing is something that you're still
formulating is the is the idea to have
point-of-care testing where somebody
comes to work they are tested every day
or every other day and the results are
as accurate as possibly can be but back
in hand within minutes
what's the goal there yeah I think
that's a useful overall concert we're
still determining what the exact
schedule would be but again obviously we
would like to test people frequently and
and this is what we would call
surveillance testing me and these are
asymptomatic individuals we'll have a
screening protocol so that if someone
has symptoms we're obviously going to
isolate them on symptoms alone but we
want to have a surveillance screening
testing protocol that allows us to test
all individuals in those tiers that we
mentioned before on a very frequent
basis so that we can hopefully detect
someone as early as possible with a new
infection hopefully even before they're
manifesting symptoms so that we can
again remove them and isolate them as
you said so that's the goal of a testing
program it will be done on sites local
to the team and the results reported
back so that as you said we make sure
that that anyone who's coming into the
team environment has has indeed been
cleared and I think you extend that also
towards game days where you want to make
sure that everyone as they come to
participate in the game has gone through
a similar type of testing what do you
what are your plans are there plans to
outfit face masks with with actual and
95 material there's talk of that being
possible that every face mask has a mask
built within it is that possible well I
would say we're exploring a number of
different options again very
collaboratively with the Players
Association we have a number of
consulting engineers that we work with
on both of our groups and so all ideas
are on the table and all options are
being looked at because again our goal
is to mitigate risk as much as we
possibly can no I would say we have very
active discussions about those types of
devices and and we continue to see what
makes the most sense
and does the best job for mitigating
risks for our players while still being
compatible with the game of football I
also couldn't help but notice noticing
with tier one and again in this club
facility protocol for the 2020 season
dr. Allen sells a couple more minutes
left with the chief medical officer of
the National Football League I couldn't
help but notice that there it it wasn't
a requirement that masks are be worn by
players coaches athletic trainers when
they're around because that it is
specifically mentioned for tier two
individuals are you planning on just
saying you know what players are around
each other and and and within the
facilities they're not going to be
required to wear masks no that's
actually not what we said initially in
most of these protocols we stated that -
that masks are not worn on the field
during the athletic competitions right
you're one individuals but we're there
in the facility if they're in meeting
rooms if they're in dining areas you
know we do anticipate that masks and
other PPE will be appropriate and I
think that's one important point
sometimes you know say well gosh if I'm
being tested maybe I don't need to
bother with all that and we don't feel
that way for several reasons first of
all no test is 100% accurate they're
always you know some things that are
that are not going to be caught by your
testing program and secondly the time
development in the course of symptoms
and when someone's infectious you know
is still to be worked out and thirdly
again the responsibility of others in
the testing environment so I think that
you know just because someone's being
tested doesn't mean they don't need to
wear PPE the the real thought behind the
testing is there are certain situations
in football as we've talked about on the
field where PPE
can't be fully worn and so there is some
risk exposure there and so that's the
thought one that the testing adds in
some extra layer of safety above which
PP alone would well I'm glad you know I
wanted to bring that to the fore you you
gave the answer that you gave because so
many people do look to the NFL for
leadership on so many different fronts
and I'm talking about society in general
and that's important for people to know
about wearing masks writ large as we go
about our businesses even if you've been
tested that doesn't mean that you
shouldn't wear one
so I guess my last question for you is
what can you tell people who are
about possible therapeutics I imagine
you are on the front lines with the NFL
in connecting with drug companies and
finding out whether there could be some
sort of medication that's either out
there as a drug that's being used for
other purposes right now that could be
repurposed to help the fight of Kovan 19
or even shorten the amount of time that
somebody could be within what we just
established potentially a kovat 19
protocol what can you tell people about
you know what you know about
therapeutics for the Fall well I remain
very optimistic that we're gonna see
some major advances made in therapeutics
and really in all these areas and I
think one point to keep in mind that's
related to that is I know that for all
of us it feels like since we started
this when everything shut down with the
first class of cases that feels like
what roughly five or six years ago right
it feels like a very long time you know
it's actually only been about three
months and there's an equal amount of
time or a little more time in fact in
front of us between down the start of
the NFL regular season and so the point
is think about how much we've learned
how much knowledge has engaged how much
more we know today than we did earlier
this pandemic I'd expect this make
similar jumps and knowledge because
there's so much work being done on
therapeutics on testing on the
epidemiology and that work is certainly
going to inform us we're going to keep
that on the forefront and I'm hoping
hopeful that some of those therapeutics
indeed will come into play but again
we're just gonna have to let the medical
science work its way through three
months is a very long time to us to stay
at home and to isolate but the very
short time in the scientific world for
development of things like vaccines or
new therapeutics oh well we'll have to
remain patients but we're certainly
monitoring that very very close okay and
the yeah I guess then that's my last one
for you mentioned vaccine of so many
people out there want to know about fans
in the stands and whether they need one
to feel comfortable returning where are
you on that subject with fans in the
stands and your expectation of a vaccine
potentially in time for let's just say a
playoffs for an NFL season in 2020 yeah
yeah I think it's really hard to predict
when a vaccine may be available and the
exact same development is a lot tougher
than people think if you've been around
the medical world for a while you know
that there are a lot of starts and stops
with that and so I think that that will
we will get to the point of having a
vaccine it's just very very difficult to
put a timeline on
but I think that will that will
certainly get here I think in the
meantime as far as fans go we've
expressed repeatedly we would like to
have fans be present if it's possible to
do so meaning if it's safe to do so so
again we'll continue to work with the
public health authorities we'll look at
what the state of the knowledge is we'll
be informed by what other leagues around
the world in our own country have
learned and have done in that regard and
Wilma will make the best in the safest
decision at that point in time and as we
mentioned before you know what happens
in September could be very different
from what happens in January we'll just
have to continue to be flexible and to
adapt this new knowledge comes out all
right dr. sills I appreciate it thank
you I again I don't know if I could put
anything more in neurosurgeon terms or
doctors terms I did my best in this
conversation did a great job and thanks
for having me I appreciate you saying
that thank you that's dr. Alan sills NFL
chief medical officer hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here